hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is
um tonight i am going to be taking you
through
some really common opening mistakes that
i see from a lot of beginners and we're
going to go a little bit beyond
just that simple you know develop your
pieces opening principles control the
center casler king
i'm going to step uh sort of one step
beyond those and get into some really
specific things
that i see a lot of beginners a lot of
amateurs
uh falling into when they sort of are
just blindly
relying on these principles i i see a
lot of games
sort of go the same sort of wrong
direction
when beginners are are sort of blindly
just saying yeah i'm
following the principles so so life is
good uh and that's going to be the topic
tonight uh it's going to be about
some really common mistakes and how to
avoid them
sometimes even how to counter them if
you find yourself playing an opponent
that is falling into these mistakes
themselves so let's
flip on over here to the board i want to
start off with a game i've actually
shown before
this uh is for long time viewers of the
road 2000 i think
a game that made an appearance in one of
the very first episodes
and i want to show it again here sort of
in a new context but before we actually
jump into that game
i want to start with something that
isn't really a game just sort of an
introduction to the idea
i'm going to be talking about so a lot
of beginner a lot of amateur level games
start like this right white goes e4
black goes e5 white develops this knight
to f3
because they've been told it's good it
attacks the pawn it develops a piece
but black is wise to these ideas and
black
usually finds the way to defend the pawn
while also developing a piece with
knight c6
white might then opt to develop the
bishop black might also develop out
their knight
to f6 attacking this pawn but
white having the advantage of the first
move has the bishop outside the pawn
chain
they might play d3 to protect the pawn
black might play bishop c5 white might
play a move like bishop g5
why not develop the bishop out to g5
pinning the knight
black might play the very natural d6
continuing development
we might see knight c3 and i'm willing
to bet
if you're new to the game of chess this
is a position that you've either
seen before exactly or it looks
very very similar to many many positions
that you have
been seeing uh and you know that
you can argue about stuff like the fried
liver attack and things like that
but for the most part the the games
aren't going down the path of the fried
liver
uh this this is sort of the position
that you're going to get when you're
first starting out of the game of chess
you start with the king's pawn
opening black often just responds in
kind if they are a beginner as well
both sides develop their pieces out and
things seem to be going okay
so at first glance it might be like yeah
this is the the opening of a chess game
nothing to see here
nothing to worry about and then both
players will keep developing they'll get
castled
and and life is is peachy then they go
on they play a very normal chess game
somebody blunders a piece and the game
ends but
i'm here to tell you that black is
actually in a
lot of danger in this exact position
what do i mean by that well i mean if
black doesn't play one of
a couple very very very specific moves
then black is just going
to be lost out of the opening on move
six
so what is white's threat chat room can
you tell me
what is white threatening to do here
what is the idea
so chess king has the right idea here
the idea is to push through
with the move of knight d5 so if black
were to play some sort of nonchalant
move
like king side castles white's going to
play knight d5
and this is the first idea that i want
to talk about ideas relating
to this early pin of this knight on f6
to the queen on d8 now if you're a
beginner chess player and you haven't
ever lost a game like this
then kudos to you because i i think
everybody at some point in their chess
career has has lost a game to this exact
idea
right you start out playing the king's
pawn opening you go e4 e5
next thing you know your knight on f6 or
even on f3 this can go
both ways as well is pin to your queen
and you have no good way of stopping it
but if you're
really a beginner at chess you might not
understand what the big deal is right
sure the knight's pinned but it's
defended by the pawn and the queen
so what's the problem here well the
problem is if
uh let's say we were to continue the
game with some
developing move like bishop e6 the
problem now is that
black's king side is going to be totally
fractured
after g takes f6 and this is going to be
a winning advantage
for white and we're going to see this
exact idea
in our first game but i just wanted to
introduce this idea sort of in its most
basic form
you sort of achieve this type of
position
just by very natural development very
normal looking moves
that i think everybody has seen played
and played themselves
before right just seemingly random
developing moves but
somehow someway black is in deep deep
trouble here
unless black plays you know a very
specific way
so quickly before i get into real game
examples
um what can black do against this idea
black is
in fact not just lost in this position
number one
black has an interesting idea to attack
this bishop directly now if knight d5
were to follow there's a knight takes c4
and a c6 and the point now
for black is that uh he has not yet
castled king's side and the move rook g8
is going to come
and black is is better here uh perhaps a
little bit more
sane is the idea of h6 when after bishop
h4
you get something similar but we don't
need to double our pawns
we can in fact just sort of launch an
attack on the king's side like this
and lastly if none of those ideas look
appealing to you
it's not too late to just play bishop e6
and take this knight on d5
perhaps this is the worst of the options
for black
but this is not going to end up being
like a 20 move loss or anything black is
going to be
doing perfectly perfectly fine here
uh okay so questions on this before we
get to
sort of a real game before we get to a
real game
questions here
all right well let us move right along
then
to our first real game example so this
is a game
between uh two players francesco dune
who's now actually a canadian national
master
but at the time of the game i think it
was about 10 years ago now
he was about 1500 and he he was playing
as someone of similar strength by the
name of
david chang so let's jump into this game
between two
you know not total beginners but class
level players and see how these ideas
are working out
in their games so we have e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5
a6 bishop a4 we get a
roy lopez uh black plays a6 making the
bishop move
often times black will continue out now
with b5
and while these might not be as basic uh
moves as beginners might be used to with
just pure
raw development uh it's it's still very
much in the same vein black isn't really
wasting time
because white wastes the time back uh by
moving the bishop that black wastes by
moving upon
black then does get developed with
knight f6 we see kingside castles
and now b5 so once again black wastes
time by moving upon
but white has to waste the time back by
moving the bishop this is all very
normal stuff so far black takes some
extra queen sight space
but it might get attacked by white a
little bit later on but we'll see that
that's not even what's going on
in this game black now continues by
developing the bishop outside the pawn
chain with bishop c5
still very normal and then white takes a
slightly more conservative approach
with the move d3 which it's perfectly
fine right this is
exactly what you would expect to see
from maybe a 1500 level game
neither player making any egregious
opening mistakes
both sides controlling the center aiming
to castle and in fact getting castled
after our next move
but you know neither player really going
deep into theory
and trying to to prove some opening
advantage right you just get your pieces
in the game
and then life is good uh and then that
starts to change
after white's next move white plays
bishop g5
and once again we are seeing a lot of
the same ideas
that we just looked at right white is
just pinning this knight on f6 to d8
and it doesn't look like too big of a
deal yet but given a couple moves
this could in fact be game ending this
idea right here could be ending the game
uh in the game black ops for the move h6
which isn't a bad idea at all
white retreats this bishop and then we
see the move rook e8
by black so
this is where we sort of diverge from
known territory it's
actually pretty difficult to get a
unique position after nine moves in the
roy lopez
but the players have done it here with
the move rook e8
and just to give you an idea of how
severe this pin
actually is there there are in fact a
few games in this position
in the highest level game between
someone by the name of dejan
denev and vladimir georgiev which is
maybe a name that you recognize georgie
has a pretty strong player
in that game georgie have played the
move bishop e7
which really goes to show how severe
this pin can be
and how dangerous it can be for black if
left unchecked black
in this game uh vladimir georgiev was
willing to undevelop this bishop back to
e7
just in order to break this pin and
that's you know not not a coincidence
right it's
not because you know black just felt
like breaking the pin felt like the
bishop was better on e7 this bishop is
great on c5
it pressures the king side it controls
the d4 square
it's really because white was making
some pretty severe threats on this
diagonal
and they need to be dealt with so let's
see what happens when black doesn't deal
with it
black in the game played rookie 8 and
white continues now with knight c3
uh and it's sort of last chance here
bishop e7
or kind of bust for uh for black but
you know that being said bishop b7 still
isn't exactly the happiest move
after you just put the rook on the e
file it doesn't make as much sense
to put the bishop in front of it and
stop this rook from
from participating so in the game black
tried this idea of knight d4
but this simply doesn't help knight d5
by
white and white is just simply much
better in in this position uh okay
so last chance for black to try to
escape was to do something
super crazy super wild like g5 and
probably why it's going to end up on the
better side there
because g5 with the king castled is
going to be a little bit weakening
but in the game things just totally
collapsed black captured on f3
white brings in another attacker to this
knight on f6
and now this bishop comes back to e7
anyways
but at this point white is already able
to get a winning advantage
so you guys at home go ahead take a
second try and find
white to move and get a winning
advantage here it's not some big trick
or anything
but uh it is useful to try and find it
for yourself
so go ahead and take a moment here
so what you guys come up with
also yeah hello hello to everyone
hello peter peterson andy wall
what about the free e-pawn before d3
okay so i sort of skipped over that i
can go back in
and mention that as well
take with the bishop first then knight
checks so
yeah there are really no wrong answers
here but the the key
is to understand that white's main idea
is to force this pawn to f6 and you can
do that by taking on e7 with the knight
you can do that by taking on f6 with the
knight you can do that by taking on
f6 with the bishop all three of these
moves are great
and in fact it's it's not even too late
for white to go for queen side counter
play
but keeping in line with the lecture uh
the most permanent damage you can do to
black's position right now
is just to immediately capture and
that's what white did
white opted to take on f6 with the
knight but like i said you could take
here
and then take here uh you could take
here first
you could take here first as in the game
all of these moves lead to the same end
result
black would definitely not be interested
in keeping pieces on the board here the
more pieces on the board the
harder it is for black to protect this
king for example already queen g4 check
is
is just going to be winning the game uh
this king is
is just too shelterless and the sneaky
bishop on b3
is going to be a nice attacker as well
with queen h5
queen f7 threats coming uh so
after takes we see bishop takes by black
and
white should not sort of duck out of the
way now we take back
black takes with the queen to again get
rid of the
queens before fracturing the pawns and
then white does in fact just trade the
queens here
and this is sort of
at its base form the the least white
could be getting
from this uh fractured structure by
black right
white isn't making any checkmating
threats anytime soon
but that being said the structure is so
bad that white is in fact winning the
game
anyways so see if you guys can can find
the continuation here
now you have made the weakness because
black has fallen into this very very
common beginner opening
uh mistake allowing this pin on the
f6 knight to become too severe and now
it's time to uh to find the follow-up
how can you actually attack these
these pawns so right to move here again
chat room what do you have
and yeah peter peterson chess king
they all have the right idea here uh it
is to push with the move
f4 pip and choke says g4 i'm not sure if
this is a typo meaning f4
or if he means g4 to just sort of keep
these pawns
at bay in this case g4 just isn't really
necessary uh
f5 isn't going to be a good response to
f4 and we just
want to immediately open up this this
file and get at the pawns
so f4 it is uh and now black is
is just lost um there's really nothing
else to say uh black is dead here
in the game black tried rookie seven so
we'll look at that first
now white simply captures on e5 black
captures back on e5
and it's true for the moment that black
is not losing a pawn
but believe it or not white could
actually take immediately
and follow up with rook f1 and black
once again
finds himself in an unfortunate pin
uh in the game uh francesco chose the
slightly
less severe rook f6 uh with the simple
point of continuing with rick a to f1
and the pawn on f7 is going to fall
anyways
what else could black have tried though
perhaps king g7 was a better try
but again white can simply open things
up on this f file
now this would lose obviously to rook
takes f7
so rook takes e5 should be tried but
again
white's just going to double up attack
these pawns and black is going to have a
very very difficult time of continuing
this game
so rookie 7 in the game and then rook f6
rook a to f1
after king g7 by black and now bishop b5
white simply takes this pawn on f7 takes
back
the king comes up and white just starts
to take all the pawns on the board
rook c8 tries to defend now bishop e6
is coming to f5 and after rook h7
um i think black had already seen enough
and chose to
resign the game so 25 move game
before uh black decided to resign why
did black pick
this exact moment well for one this rook
is attacked and
for two this is a bit of a tactical
threat
so things collapsed very very quickly
here for black and
you know i i titled this over this
lecture something about you know
beginner opening mistakes
but these players definitely were not
beginners uh the 1500 level 1400 level
this is you know but a long stretch away
from uh
the beginner level in my opinion and you
know this
this is an interesting idea uh that i
think has shifted a lot more and more
people are calling themselves chess
beginners if you're like 1500 over the
board
you're definitely not a beginner in my
book you know some stuff about chassis
you sort of know what you're doing
but still these beginner opening traps
uh
what are are definitely going to find
themselves
making their way in into your games
unless you are sort of hyper
vigilant looking out for those so
now that i've shown sort of this intro
of the idea and a game where it worked
very well for white i want to show an
example of
how things might not go so well how
things might not go so well
pip and chuck is asking what do you do
after you reach the end of the road 2000
do you you go to 3 000 you take it 100
points at a time take it
five points at a time why not just next
level up road to 2005 road 2006
just keep on improving that's the idea
but anyways
we're better to turn to for a refutation
of suspect
opening ideas than the late 1800s
where suspect opening ideas were abound
and sometimes they still worked out for
players back then but sometimes you ran
into a guy
like wilhelm steinitz and he would just
crush you
mercilessly for making these early
opening mistakes so
let's take a look here at how steinitz
handled
these kinds of early bishop g5 threats
against someone by the name of serafino
dubois
so let's take a look e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 once again
we are arriving at the italian game
otherwise you know known as the
beginner's favorite opening because it's
just developing
your pieces you play e4 you develop your
pieces next thing you know you're
playing in italian
uh knight f6 was the follow up by black
and we do again see the move
d3 steinitz plays bishop c5 this should
be looking very similar to our intro so
far
white went ahead and castled black plays
d6 and next thing you know
we have the bishop landing on the g5
square
so not only is this a game between uh
serfino and steinitz but uh believe it
or not this has appeared
as late as 2019 between players like wei
yi
and alexander grishok so definitely
worth
keeping an eye on this position so chat
room
how do you think we should deal with
this idea as black
give me a couple candidate moves here
couple candidate moves
what are some ideas
it's pronounced with an sh steinitz
fair enough i thought i was getting
points already for saying w
like a v but maybe i'm getting
anti-points i don't know if that's real
um the pedro says h6 uh pippa tricks is
bishop g4 be a copycat
knight a5 has been shifted bishop e6 has
been suggested castles has been
suggested so there are a lot of moves
here that
are perfectly reasonable for black
uh bishop b6 is actually a perfectly
fine move
as we talked about before sort of
anticipating these knight c3 ideas
the one move that i would say you
probably shouldn't be doing
is castling here like once you castle
now you're getting into territory where
things might be getting dangerous for
example after knight c3
now really i think your only idea for
equality is is
going to be an immediate h6 and after
bishop h4
uh perhaps already even g5 should be
played because knight d5 is is just a
scary threat so
castles probably doesn't blow the game
just yet but i think in this position
black should be doing a bit better
so that being said the idea of knight a5
and
even the idea of knight d4 are both
perfectly reasonable here
but it's important to understand you're
not playing these moves sort of blindly
you're playing these moves with the very
specific intention of replying to knight
c3
with the move of c6 uh you want to stop
this knight
from ever getting to d5 uh maybe in this
case actually there's like a bishop g4
idea here
for for black but you know disregarding
these offensive capabilities it's
important to understand
that we have some way to stop nate uh d5
from landing on the board and sort of
crushing it so those are our perfectly
reasonable
ideas this should be six is fine as well
with the idea that you're responding to
this
with again h6 um but i think
the uh the main idea here uh
well there are two main ways to stop
knight d5 the first is this knight move
followed by c6 that i was talking about
and the second has to be this move h6
but if you do play the move h6 here it's
important to understand
you don't do what francesco's opponent
david zhang did in the first game that
we looked at which is play
bishop which is after bishop h4 just
sort of giving up and and castling
king's sight because that's how you can
very quickly
sort of become worse to these kinds of
ideas if you're not being
super vigilant what you do after bishop
h4
of course is continuing out with g5 and
this
is i'm going to say we're flipping the
script here and this is now a very
common opening mistake
made by players with the white pieces at
the beginner level at the amateur level
even at the world class level for fans
of vladimir kramnik
you know fans of vladimir kramnik or
fans of levon aronian
may both remember a famous game between
them and the candidates
where levon fell into some very similar
types of ideas
so what is the trap that white has
fallen into here
after the move bishop h4 well
in openings like the italian game like
the joko
pianissimo it's actually kind of
important
not to castle your king early and follow
that up
with these sort of moves that induce
black to to expand on the king's side
right
we've been taught a lot as beginners
that h6 and g5 is a very weakening idea
for black
but in general you know weakening the
kings weakening the king side
isn't as big of a deal if your king
isn't sitting on g8
right it's black feels a lot better
about weakening these squares
when the king is on e8 and can
eventually even head to a square like
c8 rather than being stuck on the king's
side
where all these weaknesses sort of are
so in this case
yes black is weakening his own king's
side but with these pawn pushes
black is going to be aiming to attack
the white king and the difference
between these two kings is that the
white king can't leave
and the black king can so in this case i
think black is already doing
very very well and may even be um
and just significantly better in this
position after h6 and g5 so i think this
is the best idea here
for black moves like knight knight d4
moves like knight a5 they're both
playable for black they're both fine i
don't think black is worse
but this is the best idea i think to aim
to punish
white's opening play so mistake number
one that i talked about tonight was
allowing this pin
to be uh sort of too devastating
allowing white to
pile up the pressure with knight d5 and
come after this guy
and as we talked about it uh as we
talked
about black has a couple remedies to
this uh perhaps the simplest is to move
this knight and play the move c6
stopping knight d5 outright but black in
this case
has a very aggressive option to try and
punish white's play
because white has castle early kingside
because white has sort of nonchalantly
followed these principles
black can now launch an attack because
white was too careless
with the king and that's exactly what uh
steinitz does in this game with
h6 and g5 now after bishop g3
now strength just continues with the
move h5
uh and this is just brutal stuff right
now this is absolutely brutal
uh knight takes g5 cannot be played due
to the idea of
h4 and the tactics are actually working
out in black's favor here
for example bishop takes f7 is just met
by a king move
probably to e7 or f8 and knight takes f7
is a bit of a better try but even here
it's not going to be enough
after h takes g3 this knight is
unfortunately
never really able to escape its prison
here
on the king's side and black is is gonna
be
just sort of winning by the way that's a
pin
on the king so don't even think about
opening the f-file and counter-attacking
highly illegal highly illegal stuff
so for example the simple move queen
takes g6 and black is
is winning in this position so
knight takes g5 not playable h4 is a
threat anyways
so white plays h4 himself and now black
just continues with bishop g4
pinning this knight to the the queen
and sort of flipping the script here
that being said
white isn't just or lost outright
because white does still have this idea
of c3 that we talked about from black's
perspective to stop knight d4
uh and it can and should be played here
uh steinitz
now continues with the move of queen to
d7 just sort of increasing the pressure
on
the king's side white plays d4 trying to
break in the center
but now black sort of has the advantage
and
is not going to let it go e takes d4
played in the game
now e5 played by white
but it's it's too little too late uh by
the way
uh this move would not be playable
because once again the pin is just
too strong so e5 played by white uh
black takes back in the center
white takes back black takes back and
now white tries to go for
a tactical line to save the game
unpinning this knight by
attacking this queen if bishop takes d1
it would be met by
knight takes d7 but black simply saves
the queen not interested in trading
queens
while we are attacking uh black or white
tries to move knight takes g4
but now after h takes g4 uh the
the h file is open and black is going to
win on this side of the board so
bishop d3 queen d5 played b4
and queenside castles simply offering to
uh sacrifice this piece in exchange just
for this devastating attack
uh black is just going to to deliver
checkmate on h1
so white plays c4 instead but now queen
c6
b takes c5 does play does get played now
we do zero takes h4
f3 uh rook d h8
take queen e8 is sort of
a funny move trying to cut off this
king's escape route and in fact this
move is just not very good
uh but that's okay it's the late 1800s
they're allowed to make mistakes
the game continues though with queen e2
when black is again winning after queen
e3
and funnily enough the e pawn is now
doing the job
of corralling this king g3 played
we see check check and takes
and check and takes and then steinitz
goes on to win
this position very easily with
eventually an extra piece
and then trading down to the king and
pawn end game
so there was a lot of back and forth in
that game a little bit later on
but steinitz was was mostly in control
if you didn't understand
all of it that's fine i went very very
quickly because this simply wasn't the
point of the lecture the point of
lecture
was this opening battle that occurred
right here
right after bishop g5 right black
immediately
launches the attack with h6g5 and this
is an idea that you are able to use
when white has castled and you have not
this should always be an idea
sort of in the back of your mind when
you're playing these positions with with
either color
uh in positions where black is castled
and white is not this is going to be a
good idea
and here with the colors reversed it is
the correct idea
for black so we've gone through a few
iterations now of this idea to recap
right
we saw sort of the naive variation in
the intro
where uh let's say some move like a6
white is just winning out of the opening
with knight d5
we saw sort of the 1500 level version of
these ideas
where black just didn't want to retreat
this bishop felt it was against opening
principles
and then still got crushed by the knight
d5 idea and now we see
in the late 1800s this h6 g5
idea is going to be a good one and in
fact uh
was a very good one oh sorry not with
black's king castled but here h6 g5
is going to be a very good idea as
cheyenne has managed to show in this
game against his opponent
so questions on this bishop g5 pin
in black's various plans various ways to
stop it
for four white questions here before we
move on to a second idea
how simple princess not yet so the game
itself wasn't that simple
but the point is that black got a good
position
with this h6 g5 idea and attacking on
the king side this is a good plan for
black
and that's that's the point don't worry
if you don't fully
understand the rest of the game probably
it's impossible to understand the rest
of the game at the pace which i just
showed it
what's the best reply for white so
that's an interesting question um
so let's see
let's see how um wei yi and grishak did
it
so in that game black played bishop e6
here
it looks like is that what happened
sorry just did the thing where
everything's sort of crazy all of a
sudden
so no sorry h6 bishop h4 was played in
that game
uh and then grishik didn't go for g5
just gracious just played a6
so tough to say
probably let's see after h5 i think h4
was fine i think black
or white actually started off very
strong here and then d4
i think d4 was probably the big mistake
black is sort of attacking
and d4 kind of assisted uh black's
black's attack even
even further perhaps more simple
developing moves like knight bd2
would have kept would have kept white in
the game and maybe white can even
start fighting for an advantage if black
has has played a couple inaccurate moves
so d4 is probably the the mistake here
but my advice to you
is to just not push this bishop all the
way out on g5
when you've castled and your opponent
hasn't because
you might get met with h6 and honestly
sometimes
bishop takes f6 is just the simple way
to go here to make sure you're not
falling into
any of these sorts of things if you ever
do find yourself with your bishop on g5
your king castled and your opponent's
king still
uh uncastled just taking on f6 is
perfectly fine
for white but yeah here i would say the
main move is
is definitely c3 and it's for pretty
good reason that bishop g5
isn't getting played on the regular so
other questions
can white sacrifice the knight so that's
a good question
this is an idea you might have been
exposed to before where
white can occasionally take on g5 and
win the piece back
thanks to this excellent pin on
the knight here but notably this idea is
also only really ever working
when the black king is castled with the
king uncastled this rook is going to
turn out to be a very important piece
and white just doesn't have time to add
any extra pressure to this knight on f6
and while also dealing with this bishop
right if you take the time out of your
day to play something like h4
for example uh simplest for black might
just even be to take on g5
play bishop g4 play knight h5
and once again black is going to be
launching an attack and you've really
only helped this attack
by number one sacrificing the material
and number two opening all the files in
front of your king
so definitely not with the king
uncastled definitely not
is it safer to play bishop b6 before
pushing the g slash
uh h g pawns i would argue if you're
going for this h6 g5 stuff
it's probably better to do it
immediately with the bishop still
on c8 if you go bishop e6 then your
opponent might just take it
and then you've got entirely different
positions to uh to think about here this
is
also a very common structure in these
positions obviously now
knight d5 threats are never going to be
a concern but you know your pawn can be
a little bit weak on e6
and there is a centuries old debate
whether uh over
if this structure is good for black or
not and i don't want to get into those
nuances here but bishop v6
is a perfectly perfectly fine move all
right with that
let us move on to idea number two that i
want to show off
so this one uh fans of chess
network will be well acquainted with i
wanted to introduce
uh a particular attacking idea that's
actually related
to the idea that we just looked at in
the shyness game
and that is the idea that you see here
in this game let's say knight f3 knight
c6
bishop b5 knight of six castles
uh and then i should mention by the way
somebody was asking about the free pawn
on
e4 which fans of the berlin defense
which is what was played in this game
we'll understand that it's not so free
after rookie 1
or d4 white is able to regain the pawn
thanks to pressure down the e file
and then chess is a draw so that is
where the game will end
but in this case we're gonna look at the
move knight g4
which is not a very good move but is a
very tricky move
so uh i i honestly think
that chess network has single-handedly
brought this idea
to the you know to the front of of
amateur chess
um i know i myself growing up watch some
chess network
and all that guy does is scream h2 h2
and that's the idea coming after the h2
square
so a very natural move for white is to
play h3
say what are you doing with this knight
here please go away
uh you are scaring me by attacking my
king's side
and now black is going to play the idea
of h5
so i wanted to show you this idea sort
of in its most basic form
the point here is that once again white
is castle kingside
black is not with a rook on h8 still
able to attack
and now a horrible horrible mistake that
a lot of people make
is to take the knight on g4 when black
is going to take back
and now you are simply getting
checkmated
nothing to do against the threat of
queen takes h2
if you move the knight queen h1 is made
if you move
your f pawn trying to escape i will go
g3 and again you have
no escape so this is the fishing pole
uh why is it called the fishing pole
because you put out the bait
and then you you hook them you hook them
you hook them real good that's the
fishing pole
so now once again i want to introduce uh
sort of an idea from the late 1800s i
love these late 1800s games by the way
if you ever want to learn a lot about um
the the early history of chess look at
some games from the late 1800s
and they they will show you the
beginnings of these
modern chess ideas that we use uh today
and you get to see a lot of games where
the players don't play perfectly
and when one side gets crushed for not
playing well it can be really really
instructive
so with that let's jump to another
big name in history joseph henry
blackburn
against the mysterious
lush i don't know i think this was a
game
from a simul by blackburn so lush is
sort of a no name
but we can still learn from it
regardless
uh and this game goes with e4 d5
ed5 queen d5 knight c3 queen a5
so we are now deferring from our e4
e5 sort of uh study but we're gonna see
that the fishing pole does make an
appearance here as well
and the ideas used in this game are
going to be very useful
for our bare bones fishing pole trap
that i that i just showed
and we'll come back to that with these
ideas in mind
uh white plays d4 black plays c6
we see knight f3 bishop out to g4
uh bishop d3 for white blackburn is just
developing simply
uh not trying too too hard to go after
the queen on a5 and i think this is
instructive itself
uh well yes you're not supposed to
develop the queen early because it gets
pushed around by minor pieces
on the other hand it's important not to
go out of your way to be targeting a
queen
you know if natural development is fine
for you
it can very often just be better to
develop your pieces naturally
than sort of go crazy trying to attack
the queen however you can
so bishop d3 uh e6 by black now we see
kingside castles
and bishop d6 now blackburn says
okay i see what's going on here please
don't checkmate me
i will ask you kindly to move your
bishop and what does black say
black says no i will not move my bishop
sir i will play h5
uh my name is lush and i'm here to
checkmate you
right lush trying to make his make his
imprint on chess history with this move
h5
but we'll see how well it goes for him
we'll see how well it goes
so chat room what should white do
in this position what should white do
how do we
fight this idea of the fishing pole
right
how do we fight this idea give me some
ideas chat
give me some ideas here
pip and chuck says oof the scandi almost
as bad as the french and yeah i was
linked um a very funny post by i think
jan gustafsson where
he listed all of the good chess openings
for black against e4
and he was like yeah you can do this
line and this line in this line
in the roy lopez you can play the petrov
you can play a couple sicilians
and he was like anybody who would like
like to write me an angry letter in
defense
of like you know the the kalashnikov and
defense of the dragon
in defense of you know a couple other
openings and then he just did not even
mention
the the scandinavian or the french
because he knows nobody is going to
write a letter
trying to claim that those are good
openings for black he also didn't
mention the caro by the way
but okay chat room what are you saying
don't take on g4
and that is correct here that is correct
so then there are some very good
specific moves being mentioned like
knight e4
going after the d6 bishop d5 disrupting
the queen
is uh pretty interesting as a tactical
solution
uh bishop b2 was said maybe bishop
uh either e2 or d2 is what they meant i
don't know
push the h pawn who said h4 okay so a
lot of good ideas
a lot of good ideas here so what i will
say
is i don't really agree with the idea of
h4 so let's talk about this sort of
tension that we have on the king side
here it's true that for the moment
white is not going to take on g4 taking
on g4 would be the horrible horrible
mistake
well first of all this is just
immediately hanging
um and you just you get checkmated any
number of ways here
any number of ways queen g5 queen h5
might be the simplest
even here just just queen h5 is simple
enough right you're getting checkmated
just like what we saw
but that's not to say that you don't
ever want to capture the bishop on g4
it's very easy to you know imagine a day
when for example let's say somehow this
the center does get blocked somehow some
some trade like this happens
and then you do want to take this guy
right
maybe not in this position either but
you can imagine a day
when it might be good to take a free
bishop on g4
so it's nice to just leave this little
tension here and notably
black is never able to open the h file
unless you let him
right he's just not able to open this h
file unless you take on g4
so that's the the good thing about the
fishing pole is black is really fishing
right all you have to do is not take the
bait and then you don't you don't get
bit
or you don't get caught then you don't
get caught right
analogies are tough as for the tactical
idea of d5 i don't think this is going
to be a good one here
i think black can simply take and you're
still not
really threatening to take this because
the bishop and the rook are enough at
least for
a draw for white but it is an
interesting idea to keep in mind this
idea of d5
so let's talk about what else is going
on in position number one
we have this tension where we can
threaten to take the bishop on g4
right now it's bad for us but that's not
to say it won't be bad
forever number two black is wasting time
okay i'm gonna say that again black is
wasting time
by playing h5 and he's also
committing to not castling king's side
and those are two
very very big concessions
uh to make in order to set the sneaky
little trap
of the fishing pole so black is wasting
time with h5
and he's sort of owing this tempo on
this bishop
someday this bishop is going to have to
move again it can't stay here for the
rest of the game
and on top of that now castling king's
side is going to be difficult to sort of
manufacture for black
so what should white be doing against
these fishing pole ideas
well white should be aiming to open up
the center of the board
because that's where the black king is
and white should just be aiming to
activate the remaining pieces
right black has lost time with this idea
all white does is not take the bait play
good chess moves
like knight e4 which has just been
suggested and then
the game uh continues just in white's
favor
this idea of h4 by the way i sort of was
arriving at this point but i don't think
i mentioned it specifically
i don't think this is a very good one
because we do want to maintain this
threat to the bishop
and it's not as if we're removing any of
black's threats by playing h4
right it's not like h4 was a big threat
by
black because then you know we are going
to take this bishop for free
so h4 doesn't make the most sense here
this position is going to stay closed
unless we we take on g4 so 94 was a
great move by white in the game
black plays the move uh queen c7
and white just takes this bishop off the
board on d6 it's also fine to
to not do this by the way also by the
way
uh let's say 96 queen d6 is in the game
after these moves white is perfectly
justified
in taking this bishop now right so
already
in the game white could have won by
taking the bishop and
understanding that this open age file is
not going to be
sort of the death of the death of
white's king here because we have
everything covered
we just have everything covered and
white is just up a piece
right queen d4 for example isn't going
to be good enough
we can do a number of things including
simply take this pawn
on g4 and white is winning that being
said
uh that's not what what that's not what
white
opted to do in the game and i think what
white did is perhaps
even more instructive white just says
yeah yeah right like i'm ever taking
this bishop on g4
you have no attack if i don't take the
bishop so white goes bishop e3
and black finally says all right what am
i doing and takes on f3
right just by leaving this tension here
black eventually realizes
hey my opponent's not ever taking my
bishop you know
maybe he should be taking my bishop and
they just relieve the tension themselves
and next thing you know it's like
imagine
this position and then black plays the
move h5 instead of any other move it
just doesn't make a lot of sense right
black would much rather have this pawn
in h7
and this knight on f6 or this knight on
d7
or this king on g8 right black would
much rather have all of these things
rather than this pawn on h5 and that's
the simple remedy to the fishing pole in
the vast majority of cases you just
don't take the bishop
or or knight or whatever piece is on g4
you just don't take it
and then blackburn continues out with
knight f6 rook fe1
rook to the center of the board knight
bd7
c4 by blackburn and now after rook c8 we
see even more improving moves rook ad1
and once again we see black with this
dilemma where it's like
do i really want to castle kingside
after i play the move h5
in the game lush said no played h4
and this is now the the end of the game
for lush
bishop f4 is the start of the
combination here queen e7
and now white to move and win it's d5
is the most principled approach taken by
blackburn
uh black king stuck in the center so
what do you do bring your rooks to the
middle of the board
and open up the position and this game
is just everything wrong with the
fishing pole
sort of shown in the extremes here right
black is making no threats with h5 you
just don't take the bishop
and and then you open up the center and
punish your opponent for not developing
their pieces
not castling their king the game did
continue with c
takes d5 c takes d5 knight takes d5
and then blackburn found the the nice
follow up here of bishop b5
this is a threat now with the rook on
the e file this knight can't move
without problems on d7 knight f6 was
tried trying to defend the knight
but now bishop d6 forces the queen back
to d8
and oof white to move here queen
f5 is the idea
uh black plays queen e7 we see
queen d3 queen d8 don't worry about
those moves it all becomes clear
what's going on after white's final move
of the game
so chat room white to move and win here
what is it white to move and win
one last puzzle
one last puzzle for you guys
and yeah uh christian has the right idea
here
rook takes e6 fb6 and queen g6 is made
and that was the point of
queen f5 by the way i just wanted to
show you it in its full glory
uh from the final position so rick takes
e6 and lush had had enough
and resigned the game uh queen e7 uh
avoids checkmate for a moment but you
know obviously this
is pretty busted so just to recap this
game
what happened well black played some
very natural moves
then h5 the fishing pole and blackburn
just wins the game
by simply not taking the bishop so
that's the second
big idea that i wanted to show
now with the last five minutes i want to
introduce you guys to
two players of slightly higher strength
than blackburn and lush i know it's hard
to believe
a player better than lush but here we go
and
these two players are uh known by the
names of
alpha zero and stockfish i think it was
stockfish eight at the time
of course these were earlier versions of
of both of these engines i think they
both had some some updates now
but i don't have time to analyze this
game in its full
glory but i i do want to briefly show
that these ideas don't just exist uh in
beginner games in 18
and late 1800s games or even in
just human games today these are ideas
that appear
even at this super high inhuman level of
chess so
just to show we had a queens indian
defense don't don't worry about any of
this
this is not an in-depth game analysis
but just to show you
h4 h6 and of course now white is just
going to leave this knight on g5
threatening stuff like queen h7 mate and
leave this rook on
h1 so these ideas appear even in
you know superhuman levels of of chess
what's the difference between this game
and the last game why is this good for
alpha zero
when it was not good for lush against
blackburn
well the difference here is that number
one
white is making very concrete threats on
the king's side
uh pinning down this knight to the f6
square and
number two white is not sort of losing
all this time
that we saw in the previous game right
white had to move this knight to pin
this pawn to the bishop
and now white is going to to fight back
in the center of the board as well
this game continued with knight d5
knight c takes d5 c takes d5
and again this pawn cannot be captured
because this knight
is overworked right can't defend h7 and
take on d5
and this was a very long and interesting
game that again i
i just don't have the time nor will
power to go into here
but the long and short of it is
eventually
alpha zero comes out on top proving that
the queen's indian defense is a pretty
suspicious opening
with threats on the king's side abound
and eventually
you know winning end game what else what
else how else do you end a game at the
superhuman level
so final questions for me before we we
call it a night here questions
on the first idea that we looked at
which was just this idea of
this pin on the knight on f6 early early
on in beginner games
and then this nice little tricky idea of
of the fishing pole
questions on either of these things
before we we call it a day and i say
call it a day of course there are more
lectures after this i
am going to be doing an end game lecture
and pippin chuck
thinks he's noticing a pattern thinks
he's got me pegged
i'm a rook in game guy i've been doing
rook end games for like a month and a
half now
i decided you know what i've had enough
of the rooks
let's talk about knights so i'll be
talking about night end games
uh in in just a couple minutes here so
yeah if
you do want more chess there's another
lecture tonight on end games
rather than this more opening focused
lecture um all right
that will do it uh do it for us uh then
thank you guys
uh again so much for watching uh as i
said end game lecture
right after this on the youtube channel
my name is
[Music]
you